with some curiosity I watched students
and administrators and some left-wing
politicians take part in a national
walkout to advocate for gun control
today
what parkland showed us is that this
could happen in any one of our schools
and we as students can't take this
anymore one month after the high school
shooting in parkland Florida kids at
more than 2000 schools across the nation
stage these walk outs but don't be
fooled into thinking this was some sort
of organic outpouring of youthful rage
this was a totally choreographed event
organized by a group called empower it's
the youth wing of the women's March well
thank God they didn't force the kids to
wear those idiotic pink knit caps that
would have been bad but you got to hand
it to them really come on lift this
dunno how to organize in protests
students took part by the thousands who
needs Homer in history when you can get
credit for screaming
Oh naturally
they were enabled by a familiar cast of
characters and the kinda style for all
of us together
[Music]
we're all moved by your eloquence and
your Fearless insistence on action to
prevent gun violence thank you for
bringing your urgency to this fight to
the doorstep of America okay look you've
heard of like you take your child to
work day for the anti-trump anti Second
Amendment crowd this was make your
student protest day like there's nothing
worse than people who use their kids to
advance a political agenda like many
school districts teachers administrators
and local politicians supported this
walkout the demonstrations were supposed
to last 17 minutes to honor each of the
Parkland victims but some of these
things went on for hours and sometimes
they took on an even festival kind of
party atmosphere in New York students
marched on me of course Trump
International Hotel and at the Brooklyn
Borough Hall in DC you saw that clip
they gathered at the US Capitol and at
the White House we will accept nothing
less than comprehensive gun control and
if it's what it takes we will shame our
national policymakers into protecting us
when the commander chief solution to
this country's gun problem it's more
guns you know we have a moral problem in
this White House this is in our hands
now and if any elected official gets in
our way we will vote them out and
replace them ourselves
that's nonpartisan completely the the
mention of Trump just ignore that oh my
goodness so much for honoring the
victims this was nothing but a left-wing
anti Trump diatribe you peel it all back
and it could have been written by anyone
at moveon.org while a significant number
of liberal educating a few
administrators and teachers actually had
I think a better idea
like the ones who called in to my radio
show this morning as a conservative
social studies teacher I had mixed
emotions about the walkout today but I
did make time at the end of the period
for those students that walked out you
kind of air their opinions and we had a
really good dialogue I was really
surprised to find out that they
understand that it's more than
just gun control it's more the mental
health parents needing to be present in
their kids lives and to adjust the
issues of bullying struggling public
schools did have their walkouts
but our parochial school teachers worked
with the students and put together a
program of a walk in and they went into
the churches and auditoriums and
recognized the victims with with prayer
I really like that think about that
commemorating the loss remembering the
victims prayer offered as a class to me
that makes a lot more sense than yelling
into a microphone in front of some
government building we're talking about
students here and for anyone who takes
the time to look at our academic
standing in the world students need more
academics more classroom time not more
hysterics according to the latest Pew
survey American 15 year olds ranked 38th
out of 71 countries in math and 24th and
science places like Singapore Poland
Portugal and Macau beat us by huge
margins and we're worrying about
protests and walk outs we need sit-ins
as in sit in class and learn let's be
clear here Democrats are using these
kids to whip up enthusiasm for the
midterms 2020 and beyond and of course
for voter registration it's theater with
real-world consequences because I'm
telling you when these placards are
trashed and the TV producer stop calling
Johnny still won't be able to read as
well as some of those other countries
maybe not write as well or distinguish
between a polynomial and a Polliwog
political activism is terrific I love it
but it should not be conducted during
the school day so a few kids want a
protest have at it and it probably
better after you graduate from high
school but for now your education and
your studies are far more important than
any March even if the politicians and
the activists try to convince you
otherwise and that's the angle